[MUSIC]
Good afternoon.
My name is Paul Reist.
On the behalf of the Oral History Program
of the GSB library,
I'd like to welcome you to today's event,
an evening with five deans.
I wish to thank our panelists.
For this extraordinary opportunity.
And a special thanks to Dean Saloner for
moderating the panel.
Our panelists probably need no
introduction.
Nevertheless, they are starting closes to
me, A.
Michael Spence, R.J. Miller, our current
dean, Garth Saloner.
Robert Cheteky and Robert Joss.
This is an historic moment.
Never before have five deans of the
business school
been assembled together on one stage.
So, we're looking forward to a really
great hour.
And now, please join me in welcoming our
distinguished panel.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Well it's a real honor to be here this
evening.
I'm not sure that it's possible to
moderate this crowd but
I'll give it my best shot.
it's, it's of course an honor to be up
here with with the four of them.
Anybody who's fortunate enough to be the
Dean of this institution stands on
the shoulders of all of ones predecessors
and to have four
such distinguished predecessors with us
this evening is a remarkable opportunity.
And I, I feel so honored to be here with
them.
The GSB today, I think is in, incredibly
good shape.
We're sitting here in this fabulous
auditorium.
The Cemex auditorium.
In our still relatively new Knight
Management Center.
We have embedded in it a new curriculum
that we put in place six years ago.
We are the most selective business school
for MBA students.
Taking still fewer than 400 a year out of
the roughly 6.5 to 7.5 thousand
who apply and we have really transformed
ourselves into a school that aspires
to admit a relatively small number of
incredibly high potential individuals.
And then, given the opportunity in a two
year in the case of the MBA or
a one year in, in the case of the Sloan
program.
Highly immersive a transformational
experience that helps them
become change agents that can take on the
biggest challenges in the world.
Because we all know that the world has,
has very significant changes.
A whole variety of fields.
And we aspire to educate those leaders,
who can go out and
really tackle these big challenges.
And so the, the question i'd like to
really start with this evening is,
how did we really get here?
Right?
We, we look around,
we kind of know, know where we are and
this is part of an oral history project.
And so I thought let's tell, let's tell
the story a little bit because we have
here on the stage the people who made that
history.
And so I'm gonna start, R.J. with you.
And what I'm gonna ask each of the deans
chronologically to do is,
tell us a little bit about what you found
when you came here.
And what you tried to do.
And then, your own assessment of of what
you left when you,
you hand the, the reigns over.
And we'll go around the group.
And then that way we'll tell the story
over the decades.
>> Thank you Garth, I'm glad to be here
this afternoon.
As a matter of fact I'm glad just to be
alive.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Most people born in 1916 are dead.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> When I agreed to take this job
we had full agreement that there would be
a public management program added.
And that all the students, or for
all the students in the school, the
curriculum would be expanded.
The all would be expanded.
When I arrived on, there, I understood.
That there would be an increase in cost
because of this, when you hire professors
like [UNKNOWN] and Harry Roland and George
Schultz, you know it's gonna cause
something, but I was prepared to take on
the added cost of that, that undertaking.
When I arrived on campus, I was shocked
because I learned that the new president,
Ken Penser, had set a rule that the
business school could not
spend any more than a fixed dollar amount,
believe it or not.
I had received a grant from the Ford
Foundation to
teach students from the school of
education, something about management.
We spent the money on the course,
developed it,
got the check from Ford Foundation, which
went over to central administration.
And Ken Kester pocketed it.
>> [LAUGH].
>> We didn't get a dime of it.
I insisted on getting a meeting with him.
They're trying to get him to change the
rule, but he wouldn't talk to me for
the fist six months I was on campus.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I went over his head
to the chairman of the board of trustees
of Stanford at that time, Carma Fuller,
and told him that if I didn't get the rule
changed, I would resign.
He was sympathetic to how I was being
mistreated.
Ask please ask me to stay on and
be patient and that other people were
unhappy with Pister.
I got the idea that Pister was gonna be
fired.
He was fired on August 1.
Nick Lyman came in and in eight days I had
a five year
written contract that anybody but raised
above 500,000 could be kept.
[UNKNOWN] was the dean of the business
school here at Stanford at that time.
And he advised me that if we increase the
academic freedom of the school.
We would get even more freedom, so we made
that a number one priority.
In those days, the deans of all the
business schools in the US voted.
And in five years the voted us number one.
I think our inde, financial independence,
a,
additional freedom has served the business
school very well over these years, Garth.
And that formula is still in place.
You asked some other question but I wanna
talk too long but about-
>> [LAUGH]
>> You know, what contributed to
good times we had but turn it over back to
you.
I think-
>> Well-
>> That's how I got started here.
It was a little rough but
it turned out okay.
>> [LAUGH]
[APPLAUSE].
Well, thank you RJ and, and of course the,
the formula base that you established with
the University which has allowed us
to keep the money that our Alumni have
wanted to give for the specific purpose
of supporting the Business School has
served us in, incredibly well.
Over the decades and we owe that to you.
And so, from that onto you Bob.
What did you find and, and what did you
really hope to do during your tenure?
>> Let me pick up int the 60s because I
was RJ's associate Dean and
that, he was really my mentor.
it, it, it was I guess the other piece of
background you,
you sort of have to cover is that, if you
looked at the industry, and
you said sort of how does business
education stack up.
And, let's say that [COUGH],
let's say the 50s and the 60s, early 60s,.
It, it was, and keep in mind that the Ford
Foundation and
our own Jim Howl and Aaron Gordon,
economist up at the University of
California sort of did a landmark study on
the status of business education.
And so there was a blueprint that was sort
of beginning to emerge.
But, the, the idea was, you really need,
we
needed to upgrade academics of the program
and the, the kind of education that.
That led to an MBA that led to any, it,
all, all of the professional program.
And, that didn't come just from us.
I mean that was, sort of the status of the
industry I guess as,
as viewed by well two economists.
But, but it was a very good study.
And there were others that sort of
corroborated that.
So and, and one of the things that they
suggested would,
would improve would be to, to pull into
the business school
disciplines that in those days were a
little bit foreign to the business school.
I.E. economics, behavioral science,
operations research.
Today you'd say political economy but
whatever the version was of political
economy in those days, and that was,
and, and, and that sort of began I think
it's fair to say in the Arbuckle career.
And all of us up here would, should be
very quick to tell you that,
that you never start with something that's
blank.
We all build on the shoulders of those who
came before us.
So, you know, it's kind of a tragedy
today, in some sense, I think,
that you can't hear from Arbuckle and J.U.
Jacks who brought you, brought us through
the Depression and World War II.
That was no small feat.
And he was dean for 25 years so it, you
know, we, we, we started with
a school that had high quality even in
those days and the,
the idea was, how do you improve it?
How do you improve it?
How do you get kind of, move it along to
where it is today?
To infuse the disciplines of the business
school, then you had to help them
try to figure out how do you bring your
discipline to bear on something,
on the profession programs which was to
say managerial leadership.
And it wasn't obvious, but there were some
guidelines that you can begin with.
Well I, I think it in, the, the,
the school as I knew it and sort of in, in
RJ's era is when it kind of begin.
And this I don't know maybe sounds a
little corny today, but the, the, the,
somehow there emerged a name that said, we
called it balanced excellence.
What it really meant was.
We wanna do, a, as a single faculty, not,
not have specialists so that some did one
thing and some did another, but as a
faculty we wanna do outstanding research.
But we also wanna do an outstanding job of
teaching, formulating, and
teaching the professional programs.
And to do it as a single faculty.
That's like saying you wanna to do the R&D
and
the production and the sales all in the
same group.
That is not an easy model.
And but, but we felt that was the best way
to do things like bring
the disciplines to bear on managerial
education, leadership and, and management.
We also felt that, that any of the
professional programs
needed to be rooted in, in strong academic
research.
And you have to keep in mind, research is
sort of the only activity that people and
that faculty engage in, it's that, that
builds their intellectual capital.
Practically everything else we do, you,
you, you're living off your capital.
Well we started that model, and as, and,
and we made it work.
But of all the things that are good in
almost any academic university,
when you say, how does it start?
It's the faculty and the students who make
it happen.
You know, the, the, the, the deans can try
to help formulate the direction.
RJ was great like Ernie was at providing
resources, so that one of the things that
struck me when I came here was, I never
heard the words, I can't or we can't.
We heard the words like well let's see
what we have to do to do it.
And so good ideas were implemented.
But when you say where do the good ideas
come from and how did they implement it,
you've got to have a first class faculty
very deep in their disciplines.
Who wanted to take on managerial problems.
They wanted to lead.
That's something your faculty has was
noted for
at the very beginning is leading the
changes that are going to occur.
But there's only so many hours in a day.
Research and teaching are very different
activities in some sense and it,
it's like I'm sure the faculty felt, we're
living in two worlds.
we, we need about a 28 or
a 30-hour a day to get all this done, but
it's the same on the students.
You have to have first class students who
wanna learn in that kind of
an environment.
And that's always been the characteristic,
so the idea was, strong academic programs.
Professional programs resting on
outstanding research,
outstanding scholarship.
And the other thing was, if you could link
those two together.
Th, the courses would keep up.
They would even lead the changing who were
taking place in the world.
And you can see this today.
I, I, I still read, with this one last
comment.
I still read the annual report very
carefully.
Well if you look at the annual report, for
example for 2012,
you find something like about 60
publications.
But you also find 25 new courses and I bet
that if
you looked at the change from one year to
the next in the elective structure.
You'd probably find 20, 25% new material
in those courses as well.
And so, you say where does that come from?
Well it comes from the academic, from the
research base.
And the faculty and the students are the
ones that make that happen, and
you have to have that that interchange.
And of course, you all have mentioned the
PhD program there is no
question that the PhD program in this
school is an outstanding program.
And it's got to rest on a research base.
There's got to be links to a research
base.
But, you got the faculty and students to
thank for making this happen.
I guess it's very gratifying, I'm sure it
is to RJ,
it is to me, that they're still doing it.
>> Mm.
>> That they're still doing it.
And all you have to do is look at the
program today,
and if anything you'd probably have more
political economy.
You got more of the disciplines reflecting
themselves.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> I've spoken too long.
>> No.
>> [LAUGH].
>> No and I'm, I'm gonna, I'm gonna ask
you a follow on before I, I turn to Mike.
Because, you know, one of the things that
fascinates me,
I mean it is, it is a challenge even
today.
To, to hire and maintain the quality of
faculty that we do.
That's been an enduring challenge I think
for all of us.
And I, I wonder what it was like to try to
convince a disciplined based set
of scholars to come to what was really a
new adventure in those days.
Cuz there was not that was not an
established model.
>> How, how'd we the fa-
>> How to get the faculty to-
>> Well, I, I think we did two things.
One was, we were able to convince some
senior scholars, who came here.
That were representative of, of
disciplines that were new to the business.
I came here as a faculty member in 1960,
61, I guess.
And I, I was an old accountant.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But who were the others?
Well Ezra Solomon, Allen Mann, Al Hastorf
the,
who came as the chairman of the psychology
department at Dartmouth, you know?
Fred Fong was a computer scientist from
Carnegie Mellon.
I, I was not the only, you know he said
well,
could you recognize somebody' who's
familiar with a business school?
I was probably the only one who group up
in the business school.
And that, that continued.
They got you know, there were, and the
people that came here then,
and again if you hadn't had that faculty
does the recruiting.
So the faculty had to help convince those
that,
that did come that were sorta at that
senior level that.
A, we needed them.
B, they were relevant.
C, they had to, the, the, the, they, they,
they had to learn how their discipline
could help to improve management.
But then the next phase was now is really
the scary one.
Was you go out and you try to find young,
beginning,
discipline based, research based young
people.
And you bring them in and you help them
mature.
You help them grown.
You help them develop.
And there's any number of those people
around today that
I've been here for a number of years.
And that's scary.
Because one thing the faculty had to do
and boy I'll and I,
I, I got to tell you this but I didn't
invent it.
I just tried to push it along.
If you had a group that were here, that
did the, the recruiting, and
they were trying to find people who were
better than they were.
Now you gotta stop and think for a moment,
what does that mean?
It means that maybe I ought to become a
Dean.
[LAUGH] Because I'm not gonna survive in
this atmosphere
>> [LAUGH].
>> No I, you know, you, that, that sounds
funny but boy, it, it's real.
I mean, and but, but the faculty had to do
that.
And they were willing and, and
what it meant was if you appoint people
who are smarter than you are.
It probably also means they come here with
a different set of talents.
They're different then you are.
And you sorta have to step back and
say, how many organizations do you know
that are willing to do that.
That still goes on today I'm sure.
>> Well I, I think it's, I think it's a
remarkable thing that.
>> Pardon me?
>> I think it's
a remarkable thing that you did.
[CROSSTALK].
>> Well, but, but, but the, it, it was
done at that, at that time at the school.
You know, I, I don't, I don't know how
widely appreciated it is.
But really, at that time, the Stanford
Graduate School of
Business defined the model for the modern
business school.
>> Yeah.
>> And that, that was the model, and
it is the model that has endured to, to
today.
And has really created the model for for
the industry.
>> I, I think, I, so we, we have
leadership position in the industries.
RJ said it.
Keep in mind that, what, in 1975?
This school rep or celebrated its 50th
anniversary.
And by the time the 50th anniversary, this
is only 10,
12 years after sorta early post-war.
Sorta started the, kinda started during
his era.
It was like 15 years.
The industry was saying you're the best
school in the world.
Now I, I don't think anybody, you know,
got too big headed about that.
But, but it was very very gratifying to
say the outside industry recognizes the
leadership of this school.
>> Yeah.
Incredible.
So Mike, you and I came together.
>> We did.
>> We,
you know, we came back, both of us in
different forms.
and, so, tell us a little bit about you
know, the decade of the, of the 90s.
>> Well, you've already heard the
foundation that we were standing on at
that point.
Well established and, and at one,
basically, competitively, in the industry.
I think the people who built it, including
Bob and RJ.
And Ernie and Jim Howell, and, and Jim Van
Horn and a whole group of people.
Showed a lot of imagination and also
courage.
I mean, it, you know, this is a model that
sounds great now.
But it wasn't obvious at the time it would
work.
And I have to say, I wouldn't be here.
I mean, I was an academic.
If that hadn't been the model, I wouldn't
have been back at Stanford.
In this wonderful job.
Let me however say, you know, like any
great model, you know,
there's stresses and strains that come.
And at the end of Bob's time, and
certainly moving into the 90s, there was,
there started to be questioning of this
model.
The symbol of it, of course, was the
Business Week survey.
The, you know, did an awful lot of good
things for their sales of magazines, but
put, kinda put us into a bit of a tailspin
and slightly on the defensive.
and, and I think what they were saying is,
[INAUDIBLE]
something in the balance.
You know, was out of whack.
Now part of it was nuts.
I, when I, when I got here well known
alumus of the school came in to see me.
And said, you know, the graduates of this
school aren't aggressive enough.
You know, they don't go kill people, you
know.
We hire Harvard type, and I said, well.
But I kinda like them.
And he said well they just organize the
social functions.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
I actually think that part of the culture
of the school was built along with this.
This sorta cohesiveness has turned out to
be another great strength.
A more worrying set of phone calls came in
that sounded more or less.
Remember this is when Japan was, you know,
fairly far along, and
we thought eating our lunch seems like
ancient history now.
I got phone calls saying, you know, the
whole MBA program ought to be scrapped and
replaced with total quality management
programs.
And I thought, thank you very much, put
down the phone.
And, but we did, in some sense, feel we
had to respond to this.
And one of the things that, eh, that I
wanted to add, in this kinda history, is,
one of the things we tried.
Garth was involved in this Irv Grosset,
Chuck Holloway, many, many people.
We evolved a model that, that Bob Joss
carried on, that involves centers.
It involved expanding the curriculum.
It involved bringing very talented people
from the financial side,
from business, practitioners if you like,
to come and teach together.
You know, with our own faculty.
Garth has done this.
Robert Burgelman did it with Andy Grove.
And so we, we adapted the model.
I think in a way that was consistent with
the underlying ideals.
>> Yeah it is.
>> I mean,
I always said teaching Executive
Education,
teaching with Andy Grove if you ever got
the chance.
You know, or more recently with with Pete
Wendell,.
And, they, they,
you discover things that could get
transformed into your research agenda.
It was intellectually enriching in the
long run.
And so I think that has turned out over a
period of a couple of decades to
be a really important addition.
To the way the school operates, building,
building on that model and the foundation.
The, the other thing I wanted to say.
I was sitting, sitting at home the other
night in Milan ,.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Italy is a bit of a wreck right now.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I think you should all take cover.
[LAUGH].
Thinking about what RJ was doing with the
public management program,
which is the first thing he mentioned.
You know, when you look around the world,
it's astonishing how much is
dependent on political and policy
reactions through their actions.
And I remember thinking.
Could I possibly have had the foresight to
see that politics and
political economy were gonna become an
increasingly important part of our life.
And I, I concluded the answer was no.
That R.J. was probably unique in that
respect.
But it really is true.
The other thing we started and,
and then it really gained momentum under,
under Bob Joss.
Is you know, we're living in a world in
which
the developing countries that account for
85% of the world's population.
Are now 50% of the global economy.
And business people, and we on our own
faculty, were saying, you know,
we've got to react to this.
And so, we piled on an additional
challenge, which is,
somehow we have to sort of build into our
search agenda and the curriculum.
A way to keep track, of this, rapidly
evolving world that's having a larger and
larger impact on us.
Remember in the 1960s, what went on in the
developing world,
you know, occasionally caused a fit on the
balance sheet of, you know, Citibank.
But for the most part, was largely
irrelevant.
And we were a big, dominant economy, 40%
of the global economy.
And, you know, we operated in that world.
That, that's, that's a world now.
That we're continuing to have to adapt to.
And so, you overlay on it the need to have
a research agenda with a discipline base.
And work together to build an, an, a, a,
a, you know, a,
a, imaginative, creative curriculum.
For a bunch of people who want to be sorta
managers, and
leaders, and NGO's in business and
finance, and so on.
And then, somehow you've got to find a
way.
And I know Garth still wrestles with this.
To sorta keep your finger on the pulse of
of
an enormously broad array of sorta
economic activity.
The, the last thing I'll say is it's very
important to pick the time you arrive.
And, and the time you depart, so I learned
my lesson.
I showed up in 1990.
A recession that they concocted in the
East Coast of the United States,
was rolling west with great speed,
unbeknownst to many people out here.
And it hit with a storm and then the
university got
into a fairly large amount of trouble with
the Federal Government.
Over the sponsored research sorta overhead
cost recovery.
So, some of you will remember.
And so that was fu, and there'd been an
earthquake in 1989.
So Paul Johnson and, and
many others were trying to keep the old
school from falling down.
And I thought well this is a great way to
start.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And somewhere along the way Don Kennedy
stepped aside and so on.
Well anyway, it got a lot better and by
the time I stepped down we had
the internet running at high speed, it was
marvelous we were awash in cash.
And I thought to myself, this isn't gonna
last.
And I better get out of the way.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So that.
>> Funny, that's what I thought.
>> So that Bob, Bob Joss could take over
when the bubble burst.
I didn't know it was gonna be Bob, but.
And so I made up this excuse that I'd been
a Dean for 15 years, including 9 here.
And that my successor ought to preside
over the 75th anniversary of the school.
I declared complete victory.
And turned it over to a world in
which we had a big downturn economically
followed by 9/11.
>> [LAUGH].
>> And over to you, Bob.
>> Well before, before we, we, we, we go
there, Mike.
I'm.
Reminded by seeing Carol Dressler in in
the audience.
>> Right.
>> That we have we have spoken about the
MBA program.
We've, we've referenced the Sloane program
and and Bob spoke about the PhD program.
But we've not said anything about
Executive Education.
>> True.
>> Which has been a very important part of
the school, and
an increasingly part of the school.
And I remember, you and, and Carolyn, and
Jeff Pfeffer and some others.
Wrestling with, how to approach that,
within the model that's been described.
I if you could say just a couple of words
about that.
>> Well and again, I don't mean this to
be, to chip away at the, at the model.
But Jim Howell in my first or second year
as Dean, came in and said Mike.
We're carrying Executive Education on the,
on the shoulder of, of about five or
six older faculty.
So the theory that we have a school that's
engaging with experienced executives
broadly as the faculty, is not, in fact,
the case.
And, and he said this is very vulnerable
and
he actually led a faculty group to sorta
study this question.
And we, then experimented with ways to
bring younger people in a non threatening
way.
I mean the MBA is already relatively scary
for
a newly admitted PhD in, pick your
discipline.
But an executive program is truly scary
and
yet, and, and, and the what, the way we
approached that.
Garth, you and I were together doing this.
we, we had to prepare both sides.
We had to help the junior faculty go in
there and we had to give them
an assignment where they were operating
with their comparative advantage.
And we had to prepare the listeners, you
know,
the participants in the program and say
look.
The majority of what you're gonna get is
the kinda thing you expected when
you came here.
But you're gonna be exposed to some young
people who aren't gonna be able to
speak your language in toto as an
experienced executive.
But you're gonna hear some pretty
amazingly interesting ideas from these
young people.
And that, that after some experimentation
I think, you know,
has produced a situation.
Which the executive programs have broader
faculty participation.
We probably ought to give Carol a second
opinion on this.
>> Well, and they're really thriving now,
an, an, they, they've got their, a big
boost.
And so, Bob?
Now over, over to you.
>> Well that's a great set up by Mike.
1999, if you can remember, was NASDAQ
5000.
And CNBC on the lawn interviewing our
students out here.
It was nirvana.
>> [LAUGH].
>> And more seriously, it's, it was a
great school.
I mean, we had this foundation starting
with Ernie to RJ to Bob to Mike.
Great students, great faculty, students
who were in both MBA,
PhD, executive students.
An international reputation.
You know, so.
What do you do for an encore?
But I think like you know, all great
institutions the real secret is,
can you keep moving it forward?
Can you keep challenging it?
John Gardner used to say, you gotta renew
yourself.
And I always figure the role of a leader
is to see if you can change it for
the better, and get people excited about
changing it for the better.
And the secret I think for
us, at my time, was engagement, you know,
to sit down with faulty.
Who always had ides about how it could be
better,
staff, students, alumni, recruiters, the
university.
And I found as I got more engagement
going, a lot of people had ideas about how
it could be better and perhaps how it
could be more balanced.
You know you're always trying to keep
things in balance.
It might be great for students but faculty
morale was down, or it maybe great for
faculty, but staff morale is down.
So you're, you're trying to keep everybody
in a plane where they
think wow I'm part of a great school, and
I'm part of helping it to be great.
So one thing led to another and I think
that process of engagement,
of talking to a lot of people about simply
answering that question.
You know how can we make a great school
even better?
We began to hit on three big themes.
You know that we call the three C's,
[COUGH].
So I can remember them every time I went
out to talk.
The first C was curriculum, that we
thought we needed a new curriculum.
To really engage students,
one that was more global, one that was
more tailored to individual differences.
One that was more about leadership and
communication.
And a faculty group headed by our next
Dean, Garth,
really put forward an astonishing and, and
exciting and challenging new curriculum.
That we thought would bring the culture
much farther along than it was.
So that was one thing.
Then I thought, a new collaboration with
Stanford.
We were beginning to enter an era where
Stanford was doing so
many exciting things, tackling big
challenges, big problems.
Human heath, the environment international
peace and development.
and, and so we we just thought there were
ways in which we as a school could be
more engaged with the university and vice
versa.
Our students with other graduate students,
our faculty with, graduate students.
Who are gonna become future faculty
members and or
participants in other institutions.
So that collaboration was a secondcy and
the combination of that led me
to something I never expected to even
worry about.
Which was a new campus, because we,
when I came I inherited really some great
facilities.
Mike had been successful in getting the
Schwab Center across the street built.
That was a transforming investment in the
school.
He had the new night building that you was
you know,
hooked onto the little field center.
And so, we, we thought no, we're okay for
facilities.
But, increasingly we just thought for that
curriculum and for
that collaboration the, the kinda
infrastructure we need.
To enable all of this to really come to
life and really sing was a new campus.
So, that curriculum collaboration campus
course did lead to
a fourth C I didn't talk much about, which
is cash.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Again though, you stand on the
shoulders of those who've gone before.
I mean, Mike had done a fabulous job of
cultivating some very supportive alums.
People like Phil Knight, Bob Bass like
Chuck Schwab.
And who continued to be excited about the
school and
we could add to that a whole team of
people.
Who had found Stanford to be
transformative in their lives.
And they wanted to make that possible for
other and, you know its fantastic what we
have today.
But it gets better.
You know, and I think as long as we
continue to try to change it
for the better.
Then that's, that's what a dean's all
about.
So you try to pass that baton to the last
person.
RJ followed Ernie,
Ernie said you know ten years, you gotta
repot, that's enough time.
RJ said ten years, that's enough time.
Bob said that, Mike said nine, I don't
know, he trumped up this nine year
thing that I said ten years that's enough
time and over to you.
>> Well thank you, thank you for that.
So Mike made the comment that that it's
all about timing.
And and I'm the one up here that got that
right.
So so you want to become Dean.
When you're putting the finish touches on
a brand new eight building,
Knight Management Center.
When the curriculum is in place and and
really, how many,
when we're you know, more than halfway
through an incredible campaign.
That had as a goal, 500 million.
Which, I think at the time we'd launched
it seemed out of reach and and and
ended up way surpassing that thanks to.
The, the incredible generosity of our
alumni.
So I want to say just a couple of things
and
then I'm gonna throw a few more questions
to this group.
One is that as I listen to their
recounting what they did over the decades.
One of the things that really strikes me
is that all of
these elements that they described are
part of our DNA.
They are very much who we still are today.
So we rely on the formula model that you
built.
We still have in place the faculty hiring
and
development model that was was putting
place several decades ago.
Which is the core, the core strength of
the school.
Balanced excellence, we still talk about
in practice.
You know, the integration of the [UNKNOWN]
line faculty with
great practitioners often at the same time
in the same classroom.
Right?
Which you know really, you gave the,
the, the impetus to, the, the group, the
collaboration with the university.
The fact that we are part of an incredible
university,
walking distance to every school.
This is something that virtually no other
business school has all of
these elements which you, you know defined
your eras.
Have become part of our DNA and have
continued and and
a great part of, of the strength of, of
the school.
The final thing I will say and then, then
I'll change the subject here a little.
Is, is as I look out into the second row I
see I see Bob and Dottie King.
Will you, will you take a bow.
So Bob and Dottie as you know about 18
months ago,
gave an incredible $150 million gift.
To, to the business school and the
University.
To help us launch a new institute, that's
focused on, on global poverty.
It's, it's called SEED, the Stanford
Institute for
Innovation in developing economies.
And I mention it because I have been asked
a, as Dean.
You know if you, if you talk about global
poverty, the,
the next words out of your mouth are
usually not business school.
Right?
And, and so,
what is a business school doing taking on
something not just of, of this magnitude.
But seemingly this different from from
your heritage.
And of course for us it's about
entrepreneurship and
about manage manages of growing
enterprises and developing economies.
Both of which are things we we know a lot
about.
But I think our willingness to take that
on goes back to the,
the roots in the public management
program.
And the idea that we're educating, not
just functional reasons which will
take on, you know, specific functions in
corporations, but real leaders.
Who can take on the big challenges.
And, and that's one of the challenges that
they're taking on.
And represents another step, I think in
the evolution of the school.
So I'd like you to reflect, and I'm not
gonna go in any order, you
can take this in, in, in any order you'd
like, Audrey, you wanted to jump in first?
>> Yeah, I'd like to comment.
That one of the criticisms against the
public management program.
Is so very few people of our graduates
would end up
public work after they graduated.
Well they couldn't.
The salaries were too low after they paid
all the costs here at Stanford.
But I, I maintain that was very successful
program to broaden their curriculum for
a number of reasons.
Yeah.
>> First of all, our students, men or
women that go into business.
I think make more successful businessmen
because of
the broader training that they're had here
at Stanford.
If something pops up on.
The need for air and water cleaning and
safety or rising wages.
They know what the other world is about,
or
they'll respond to it more, more
successfully.
So, next business is the most powerful
force in our society,
and business men, well educated.
Would support needed social legislation
instead of opposing it.
I believe that 25 years from now, we, this
generation will be severely criticized for
not doing more in the area of climate
control.
Also, I believe that our graduates with,
with the broader base they get.
From the dual disciplines and other things
you've been hearing about up here.
Will be more willing to participate in
community life.
They'll go on school boards, part time
political appointments.
And then later on, after they've, kids are
though college and
they're got secure financial arrangements.
They may accept full time political
employment they might even run for
office, and take other, non-profit jobs.
Some of them might even turn to
philanthropism.
I mean word here from Bob King and his
wife and Phil Knight and Bob Bass so
that can't be all that bad.
And then lastly, I think our graduates
will lead a more satisfying life.
Because they will have, have a broader
viewpoint of what the world is about.
The fact that they made some contribution
other than in business.
Will make them feel like they've had a,
a part in making this world a better place
in which to live.
A magazine man once said that,
described Stanford as the business school
with a conscience.
I like that.
I think that is an advantage that we can
play on in the years ahead.
>> Yeah.
So maybe we can follow up on that, because
one of the things that, that [UNKNOWN] and
I spoke about.
Expansion of the centers while you were
dean.
And one of the centers that you launched
was the Center for Social Innovation.
So would you, would you talk a little bit
about that,
and the connection of that to, to this
worker and public management?
>> Well it really, I think the Center for
Social Innovation really built on RJ's
vision for public management.
It was a broader vision to pretty much
echo what he just described.
That it's not just about going into public
service or managing public enterprises.
That's important.
Can we get better management in non-profit
NGO and public enterprises?
But can we get a different kinda
management in our for-profit enterprises?
and, and a way of thinking and a way of
approaching problems.
I was here before R.J.
when Lee Bok was a great teacher and I was
privileged to have him for class.
And, he had a class on government and
society and business and
he'd always end every class with what's
the role of business in this?
We'd have some big public problem and he
said well what's the role of business?
And he pushed us hard, we need to do that
more again, we need to,
you know things come back.
And I think with our feeling with the
Center for
Social Innovation was what's the role of
business?
How can business make this better?
I mean, business is doing so
well, enjoying so many advantages from
globalization as Mike says.
That it has to be feeling a sense of
responsibility for these much,
much bigger problems that the university
has a capacity to tackle.
>> So, I wonder if we can give the
audience a little bit of of an insight
into, of what it's like to sit in the
chairs that each of you have sat in and
in particular what would you say is the
biggest challenge.
If you were to pick one.
The single biggest challenge that you
faced as Dean.
And if you look back, and I know it's hard
to focus on one thing,
what would you say was your single
biggest-
>> Challenge?
>> Well challenge and then accomplishment.
Would you take both of those [UNKNOWN].
>> Well, when I was Dean,.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Certainly one of the biggest challenges
was is in the 80s technology
was just exploding and you know, what,
personal computers
sort of came out in force in 81 or 82, or
that not very long ago.
And, and you, you can imagine how how
does that effect the school and how should
we exploit it?
It was clearly a very powerful force.
And, but,
you had to sorta figure out things like
what do you do about the library?
You keep buying books?
Or, then, what, what do you do about,
you've got all
this computing technology out there, but
it didn't talk to one another.
And so you wanted to embed it in the in
the teaching programs.
But you can't get faculty due to course
development to do
that if they don't know what the machinery
is.
And it couldn't just, you couldn't just
say to students, bring your own computer,
it wouldn't, how would they communicate?
And it was almost like that's, that's one
reason I thought in 1990 it was
a pretty good time to get out, Michael,
because [LAUGH] technology I'm sure
beca became sort of the single biggest
number in the budget.
And ours was only, I don't know, ten, 12
million.
Yours was 180 million, you know.
But, but that was that was part of it.
How do you deal with that?
And you know that the [SOUND] the school
to its credit said.
The only way to do it if we're gonna build
it into the, the teaching programs is
you can bring whatever computer you want
but there'll be a computer here.
That the, that the faculty can count on.
And so we almost created a second library.
Like we, you know, its a sort of a
computer services.
The other things was globalization, which
you guys have made,
you've got more political economy in this
school now than we
ever dreamed I think it'd have back in the
80's.
And then in business and changing
environment.
What it, sort of, changed you had to
understand the political process.
So go and hire a political scientist.
I mean we became like, especially under
the 90s and
the end of the 2000s, you're almost like a
mini university.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So you, you draw much better on
the university as well as the silicon
valley community.
Was there something like 50, 50, 60,
lecturers on this [UNKNOWN].
>> That's right.
>> Most of them drawn from the community.
You've got courtesy appointments that run
both ways that
probably number in the 30's or 40's?
30, 40, pe, of our people who hold
courtesy appointments in other
disciplinary departments and the same
coming in.
You've gotta be a respected member of the
academic community in
order to make that happen.
But I think it was either, sorta the
technology and
the globalization that, that, that were
th,
those were the biggest issues that I, I at
least they were two very big issues.
>> And, and if you were to point to a
single accomplishment from
your dean-ship that your, your proud of.
>> I you know,
>> Easy.
>> Deans don't accomplish that much.
>> That's right.
Yeah, you're in the right place at the
right time.
This, this [UNKNOWN] RJ once told me that,
that, I said, RJ, you're the expert on
this.
What, what are the characteristics of an
outstanding CEO or leader?
You remember what you told me?
Said, the most important thing is, huh?
>> The dogs have to eat the dog food.
[LAUGH]
>> No, that wasn't it.
You, you told me,
the most important thing is that the CEO
has to love the organization.
That all sets a lot of mistakes you know?
Because and then you could name people
that were
you thought maybe not all that good in the
technical sense.
But they love the organization.
They were just outstanding.
That's the way I feel about this
institution.
And it's the way everybody feels about the
Think what would happened if we held this
event and there was nobody out there.
>> [LAUGH].
>> You know, and that hasn't happened, you
know it,
all these people love the organization as
much as we do.
That's the, that's, that's the thing I
remember the most.
>> The main, the main job of the Dean is
to create an environment so
the professors can go to work
successfully.
My big challenge was something I failed
in.
I thought that criteria for admission to
the school was terribly important and
I tried to get some professor interested
in that subject but
failed during the ten years.
You may not remember this Garth but when
you and
I were having lunch with Jim Van Horne I
mentioned the subject and
a few days later you came up with two
professors that were interested in it.
Two great ones [UNKNOWN] and, and Otis.
And, a few days late Jim Van Horne and I
got with them.
And they said they were willing along with
Eric Bolton who he'll be the director of
admissions to undertake a robust
multi-year study
on criteria for [UNKNOWN].
With over fifteen students making an
application,
trying to pick the one that's gonna be a
leader [LAUGH].
In his later life, a leader is something
more than just making money,
it's a real challenge.
They said that they would not only follow
the ones that were successful, but
also the ones that failed.
Harvard turned down Warren Buffett.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Mm.
>> I, I'm sure that these gentlemen will
turn out a great study
that will be extremely useful and very
important, and I waited for the results.
>> Yeah, well.
[LAUGH] And we thank you for, for for your
help with RJ,
I think it's a incredibly important
subject.
Mike, your challenges.
>> Well talked a bit about the my, I mean
the out, let me talk about the experience.
My predecessor at Harvard was a very
funny, talented man named Hen.
It's very skilled academic politician
named Henry Rosovsky.
And he was once asked what's it like being
dean?
And he said it's like being a dentist.
You see somebody every half hour and
inflict pain.
>> [LAUGH].
[LAUGH]
>> So
you know, not every aspect of a job is
fun.
I mean, overall it's fun but it's you know
you get to see a lot of people.
Some of them have fairly peculiar
requests.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'll tell you the, it,
the episode that, that I felt and still do
feel the most badly.
I mean, when your a Dean, you're
ultimately responsible for a,
a pretty wide range of functions, as you
are in business.
And this was the early stages of fairly
as, as Bob Jedeki just described, fairly
rapid expansion of computer systems, and
you know, we weren't that good at it.
And at one point, a back up failed badly.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And we lost some PhD thesis or parts of
them and
what not, and we got a fair amount of it
back but, but if I had to pick one
moment if you like, in which I thought
gosh, I'd really rather have another job.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That, that was, that was, that was
probably it.
The most rewarding part I think has
already been described.
It's working with with staff and people.
It's working with people you really
respect.
On the faculty, you know, the lecturers
who came in and joined us.
People of enormous accomplishment and
commitment in, in RJ's terms, broad
committment.
To the society and to doing some good.
So that, that's the most rewarding part.
And I'm like, Bob Jatki, I don't have a
clue.
I think it's sort of somebody elses job to
figure if anything useful kind of
got done on the way through.
>> All right Bob, I'm learning.
Let's focus just on the challenges.
>> [LAUGH].
>> You know, for me, I, I think by far the
biggest challenge is this balancing
act among the various constituencies that
make up an academic institution.
It's really much more challenging than it
is in business.
You know, you've got students, you've got
faculty, you've got staff,
you've got alumni, you've got recruiters,
you have the university.
And it's not gonna be a great school
unless all of those constituents feel they
have a part in that, and they understand
each other's role, and
they feel good about it.
So I, I think it's much more complicated
than it is business, and getting that
balancing act right and bringing everybody
along and everybody excited, and
respecting each other's role, for me was
the biggest challenge.
>> Mm.
>> The thing I feel the best about, I feel
great about the campus.
I'm proud of the campus, but
I feel the best about the relationship
between our school and the university.
For me, that you know when I, my search
committee, and
I see one member out there, Jim.
Said, you know Bob, just keep the
university off our back.
There was, I mean I'm probably overstating
that.
But, you know, I, look I grew up in a life
and where I was a group executive, and
you wanted to keep headquarters away, and
you wanted to keep the CEO
kind of not sure what was going on in your
line of business.
>> [LAUGH].
>> But I also have been a CEO for six
years and
I wonder, why aren't these group
executives working better together and
how can we get them to think about the
whole, and make the whole better?
And I just felt that we have a tremendous
role to play with the university and
vice versa, to make it a great university.
And I feel extremely good today about how
respected our school
is within Stanford and the role that our
school both students,
faculty everybody is playing to make
Stanford a better university.
To me I am the most proud of that it
wasn't something that I did but
it was a cultural change that's in some
ways much harder to
bring about than a physical structure like
building a campus.
>> That's great.
You know we're, we're almost coming up on
time,
but I have one more question which I'm
gonna, I'm gonna pose to Mike Spence,
because I think history will not be kind
to us in retrospect,
if if we close without a forward looking
question, of the following kind.
And the question, Mike, is this.
So in 1999, Mike stepped down.
And and I thought well, here's a real
opportunity.
I got a hold of Mike and I said now that
you no longer have a day job
why don't you join me in teaching a
course?
Let's teach a course on electronic
business.
You know it was the height of the dot com
era.
I said we have no idea what it is.
Maybe we'll learn something by teaching a
course.
And.
>> [LAUGH].
>> And we did.
>> Always.
From the skills.
>> We, we learned quite a bit.
And if I were to caricature the course.
I don't know if you agree, but if you were
to caricature the course,
the way the course went is,
every week we brought in some business
leaders from one industry after the other.
And what they said to us was, they said,
this Internet thing is really interesting.
But it's not gonna affect our industry.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You know, books, people are still gonna
have to go to the book store.
They're gonna have to pick up the book,
they're gonna have to feel it.
Books are fine.
Well, book stores are dead.
You know, travel agencies.
Well, you're gonna have to go to the
travel, you know.
The way auto, automobiles are newspaper
content, one after the other.
And that was basically what the course
consisted of, right?
As we went through.
And and conspicuously absent from that
list was higher education.
>> Mm.
>> Right?
And yet we look out there today, and
we look at this revolution that is going
on in, in online education.
And Coursera, which is one of the the
companies that have spun out of
Stanford is, is faster to two million
users, than either Facebook or Twitter.
So this is a revolution.
I mean, this is no longer a shot across,
across the bow.
Do you have views on, on, what do you
think this holds for
higher education, and for, for business
schools in particular?
>> Yeah, I mean I think these are major,
major changes I mean,
first of all in higher education in
America we're gonna have to sort of
get back in line, much like the health
care sector in terms of cost.
And, and I think one of the ways were
gonna do that is use
the digital media that are continually
being reinvented as tools.
I think the hard part, the thing that
where we are gonna have to
either experiment or wait through and or
use cutting edge
research from social scientists you, you
know, psychologists and
sociologists who study these things, is to
figure out what's, what's the right mix.
I mean, we know the interpersonal part
isn't gonna go away.
So we have to, so it's not a clean model.
It's not the kind of silly stuff we heard
in the chorus.
You know, one group comes in and
says online retail will blow away the
bricks and mortar and
the other people okay, mm, this is a, no,
[LAUGH] they're, they're gonna go.
And neither one of them is true.
You know there's a lot of problems in the
world where you
don't know the answer in advance.
Even though journalists want you to tell
'em what the answer you, and
you have to have a, a, a school like that
that has the capacity to,
and the will and the incentive to adapt
and learn how to do it.
So, I think we can be, I think we can be a
leader in that but,
I don't have any doubt whatsoever that,
that in multiple dimensions,
this will be an important part of the way
that we teach and
do resarch, well it already is with
research, right?
I mean you know how, I mean you probably
all know this but
you mean the Bob Zelleck put the World
Bank database that's just massive,
you know, it's a public resource now.
You can go look up anything you want,
essentially, about any country in the
world or any collection of countries.
So the democratization of access to
information is an important component of,
of the way we're gonna teach and learn.
>> And, and the message in that is we,
we have to continue to innovate and, and
adapt.
And we do stand on the shoulders of
others, but
future generations are relying on us to
continue to reinvent on their behalf.
And so, I do want to stay on schedule.
I could set up here and chat to these
folks all night.
I have many more questions unanswered.
It's such a, such a pleasure, such a joy
to sit here with you.
I wanna close, with an observation that
has already come, come through in
many of the comments, that when you add it
all up, in the end, it's about the people.
It's about the people who have love of
this institution.
Who, who've come through it, as students
and being transformed by it and become,
the alumni who support us and enable us to
do the things we do.
It's about the incredibly talented faculty
in this faculty model you've described,
who take on a tremendous challenge of
bringing in their disciplines to bear.
And then developing into in fact,
if you define and redefine fields and, and
bring that that knowledge to the students.
It's about an incredibly dedicated staff
across across the school who, who work
here because of the mission and
because they share the love of the of the
institution.
And so you know all of these all of these
elements are are the people
who who share the love of the GSB and, and
therefore make the job that I
have I think not just the best job in in
higher education.
But one of the best jobs in the world.
And so I wanna ask you to join me in
thanking my
[UNKNOWN]
deans.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> And I think as usual, RJ wanted the
final word.
>> Yeah, right.
[LAUGH]
>> I've, I'm a pretty hard grader but
I like to say I think GSB, today, has the
best students.
The best faculty.
The best facilities.
The best collaborations.
The best alumni.
And under, and we're located right here in
the heart of Silicon Valley.
And under your leadership, this school
become more and
more known as the best business school in
the world.
Thank you Garth, for all you're doing for
us.
>> [CROSSTALK] [APPLAUSE].
>> We're great for that.
>> Thank you.
>> Good job.
[MUSIC]